All right.
Isaac, so good to have you
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thank you so much for giving
your precious precious time.
It's a pleasure to be here.
Wonderful.
So, if I start going over all
the things that you've done,
I won't be able to let you speak
for these 20 minutes.
I'll just give a very brief overview
and we'll fill in the rest of the
details over the next 20 minutes.
Founded a startup,
sold it to Bank of America,
Senior Vice President of Bank of America,
and then went on to be director
of various companies,
moved on to venture capital,
partner at Lightspeed Ventures,
one of the most popular ventures
here in the Bay Area.
Now founded MizMaa Ventures,
investing in early stage startups in Israel
and also the involvement
with J-Ventures.
And we've just mentioned
the love for Oded
and the capitalistic Kibbutz,
and bringing together both Israelis
and Jewish people from around the world
into this mission.
Did I get a good overview?
I have nothing to add.
It was great talking to you.
Thank you for your time.
I just saved you 14 minutes.
But I did forget one thing
that I promised we talk about,
which is the fact that you're one
of the largest Kosher wine collectors
in the world.
A real passion of mine,
something that I've been doing
for many many years.
We did our first winery in 1989
when we were living in Sacramento.
And maybe there were 10 Kosher wines
you can choose from.
And my partner at that time,
Art Huntley, came up with the saying,
"Would you boil your orange juice?"
So we went out to make really
great wines and eventually sold
it to Herzog the largest producer
of kosher one in the world.
And I've been doing wine projects
both here and in Israel
for the last 25 years,
focused around drinking and drinking
and focused around wine tastings
and position in the industry
to be in a position way better than it was
10 or 15 years ago here.
Isaac, you're one of the most world renowned
entrepreneurs, investors
and tech executives.
What's the deal with wine?
Why wine?
You know, one of the things
that really drives me is,
and we can talk about this a little later,
is being a connector.
How do you get people together?
And I think that wine,
because it holds the two components
of being Kedushah
It's both holy,
so the Friday night table,
which is where every Friday
night we have 20 people
for Shabbat dinner.
Young people, older people,
yeshiva students, Stanford students.
We have all the time.
And wine is that connector.
It's the middle man.
And you can take a non Jewish,
a president of Daimler to Israel
and do a wine dinner in his honor,
which we've done, of course.
And he walks away saying
"Israel is great,
but the wine in Israel
is even greater"
So, I find wine is really
a common, for the most part,
it's a real common bond
between people of the whole world.
Young, old, middle aged and globally.
And so, I have a good palate.
I mean, there aren't a lot of things
I have good, but a good palate I have.
And so, I started collecting and making
and producing and drinking.
And it all fits together.
Wow. Incredible. Incredible.
So, how many bottles of wine
would you say you've produced
over the years?
Well, the better question is how
many do I have in my cellar
cause what I produced is gone.
In my cellar here in Oakland,
I have about
three and a half thousand bottles.
And then in Jerusalem,
I have about a thousand or more
and they're from
every known place on the planet.
And we have Spanish wines, Italian.
All Kosher, Spanish, Italian.
Obviously Israeli, California, French.
So, it's quite, you have to come.
It's quite diverse.
I am immediately taking
you up on this offer.
The minute I heard
three and a half thousand
bottles of wine in Oakland
and a thousand back in Jerusalem.
Yeah.
Just unbelievable.
How many of them are unique?
How many of them are different?
It's a really interesting question.
We make one barrel
of something called Harlan.
Harlan is hundred point Parker,
it's the best non-Kosher wine
pretty much in Napa.
And I have a partner and I
make a barrel every year.
So, I get twelve and a half cases.
So from 2004 to now,
that's definitely the most rare,
but I have some very old wines.
I have a beautiful cellar,
so I have quite a few rare bottles
because I have some of the great Herzogs
from 1996 and '98, '99
that are still good.
So, and I have the old Yardens
from 1984 and 2000.
So, I have quite a few interesting bottles.
Okay. I have a feeling I'm gonna enjoy
quite a bit coming
for Shabbat one night.
Absolutely.
Wonderful
Isaac, talk to me a little bit about
your role as SVP
at Bank of America.
One of the largest,
largest organizations,
very, a critical infrastructure.
Very different from early stage startups
which you're involved with now.
So, especially with a broad perspective
that you can bring now,
having invested in so many companies
and seeing the whole world
of tech from young to old.
How do you see your role
as SVP of Bank of America Now?
So, that obviously I was an SVP
at Bank of America a while ago,
and I'd like to think that
everything that has shaped my career,
unlike your generation that gets to plan,
almost everything
that I've done has been accidental.
And I say that
'cause my dad was a rabbi.
He was a rabbi in the same
synagogue for 52 years.
His father was a rabbi
actually died in a synagogue
and he was 65 years in the same shul.
And I had no plan,
to tell you the truth. I meandered.
I studied technology in the early days,
but ended up co-founding
a company that was pre-Internet,
but still had a lot of the
the components of Internet.
And we did banking software
application migration for banks.
And Bank of America bought my company.
So, they were my exit.
And as part of that exit,
it was very early in the Internet cycle
and they hadn't been doing a lot
in investing in or kind of partnering
with Internet companies.
So, I spent two plus years with them
simply helping them find
early stage Internet companies
both in the US
and I convinced them to go to Israel.
So, in 1999, 2000, I started my monthly trip
to Israel since then.
Including during the intifada.
And I learned a lot about
what do corporations want and need
from these early stage startups.
And then when I got recruited to Lightspeed,
it was kind of like I went to the dark side,
which is where entrepreneurs go to retire.
But it ends up, you work six times harder
than you ever work in your life.
And I was able to apply my knowledge
from what I learned at the bank
into Lightspeed.
And then again into the future investing
I've been doing.
So, having gone through
so many investments
and spending so many years
in so many different
venture capital firms
Do you have sort of an investor persona
of how you approach this role then
and the types of things
that you'd like to see and
that you don't like to see?
The answer is the most common answer
you'll ever get.
It's about the people.
So, but I would say for me, first of all,
because most of what I do is in Israel.
It's about the nexus
of California and Israel.
Very very important at the businesses
that we look at.
Now, that is all true up until MizMaa,
which I started in 2016,
'cause that's much more
focused on the East.
But up until then,
the vast majority of my focus
was really on building companies
in California and Israel.
So, great entrepreneurs,
for me more than anything
work ethic, it's gonna sound strange,
but for me, work ethic is about
as important as anything else
that I look for.
How quickly do I get my emails returned?
How quickly ... phone calls.
If we talk about you'd like
to meet someone in Company X
and two weeks later
you send me that information,
I'm not interested in investing in you.
So, that's one of my first tells
or first signs
is work ethic energy -
I wanna focus on this
because this is fascinating
and I don't get to talk about this often.
Talk to me a little bit about this.
The efficiency and responsiveness
that you're looking for
because this, it also seems almost
this is kind of a new age idea
that we need to be very responsive.
We need to be very communicative
and sort of all the time with our phone.
So, talk to me about
this approach of yours.
So, even even back to the,
I started in the '80s, remember?
But even in the '80s and the '90s,
if I got a phone call,
I returned that phone call.
If I had a list of to dos
to do for the day,
I didn't go to bed
until I finished that list of to dos.
And so, for me, it's been kind of my DNA
from the beginning.
But I think the problem with today
is that there's always
someone better than you.
There's always someone working harder.
There's always someone more engaged.
And at the end of the day,
the person's gonna win that race.
Clearly, it's about intellect
and working efficiently.
Obviously, that's true.
But there's so many people
who are so connected and so energetic
that I think
you have to be one step more
in order to really beat
the guy next to you
'cause you only have to beat
the person next to you.
It's not about you know,
there are five competitors.
You wanna be the one
or the one of the two that wins.
It's like the joke
that I think my father always told me
that if you're in a forest
and you're with your friend
and a bear is chasing you,
you don't have to outrun the bear.
You have to outrun your friend.
Yeah. And you know what?
That's a great story.
That's how I would say
one of the key aspects of people,
when I look for people,
that's what I'm looking for.
Interesting.
So, besides the responsiveness
and the clarity,
how they communicate,
are there other aspects
about their work ethic
that you're able to judge
along your due diligence process
or simply the relationship
that you're building with them?
No, obviously I
especially in Israel,
because I've been there since 2000.
I rely on
a very heavy network of people.
Now, your generation is
different than mine.
So, if I were to ask about
what unit you were in
and what you did there.
You know, the truth is
you can most probably trick me
all day long
because I'm just not,
even ... every month.
And so, at MizMaa, my new fund,
which we've been doing
for almost four years,
we have an ex Air Force pilot,
F-16I pilot named Yoav,
who will look at you
and in 30 seconds, know.
Right.
And then we have,
my oldest son who did his degree
at Princeton in cyber-security,
and my middle Ariel who just popped in
He looked at a thousand
companies last year.
And then we have this guy, Rick Kaplan,
who was the former CEO of IBM
in Israel, etc.
So, what I'm able to do is use
their on the ground current knowledge.
And then I could call Yoram Tietz
the CEO of Ernst and Young.
And he says, "Yes.
Now let's talk"
You can sit back and relax
with the guys who smoke cigars
and drink whiskey.
So, it's kind of like
a two phase approach.
And I'll know everything
there is to know about you.
So, that's critical
along with the work, energy
and your creativity to really help.
And, of course, what you're doing
and who the competitors are.
But that's traditional for everybody.
I think it's incredible.
So, today, even though all the information
is sort of out there and accessible
And all our social media profiles.
You know people in my generation
just love to use them to not brag,
but to showcase our professionalism
and that's sort of where we wish
the due diligence would take place.
You're approaching this much more personal,
relationship oriented place of
we understand the cultures
and we know the right people
and we can actually get
to the bottom of who you are.
We don't have to rely
on these more superficial titles
that you might give yourself
on LinkedIn or elsewhere.
It's a great summation.
I'll add only one thing to that.
What I found throughout my career,
but more now than ever.
By using some of the metrics
and criteria that I have
when the chips are down,
and the chips are going to be down,
it's you I can depend on
that are gonna go that extra mile,
spend the extra day,
be the extra honest versus
someone who'll say,
"I'm gonna throw in the towel"
So, that it all builds up
to not to when the times are good
that's pretty easy.
It's when the times are bad
I plan for it.
Definitely. So, you've had the pleasure
of seeing a few bad moments
in our economy.
During your tenure
as a venture capital partner,
both the 2008 crisis that I'm looking at,
but also covid-19.
Do you actually start seeing
these aspects come out
in the entrepreneurs
that you've invested in
and how they deal differently
with these crises,
and whether their leadership emerges
or sort of succumbs?
Oh, it's like after
the first hour meeting.
Not when we start with them,
but in these times the difference is
across some of the CEOs,
both in our portfolio.
Plus, I've been investing
for a long time,
so I have other investments
across different businesses.
It's stunning.
The difference is the people that,
after our first meeting,
have already come up with solutions.
We've created this concept.
It's really a cool concept called
a growth committee,
even though it may be a bit
of a misnomer, in which
we take two of our partners
and then another VC
who's in our deal and the CEO,
and we meet every week,
every 10 days to talk about
how can we help the company
in this time.
And some CEOs
have changed their businesses,
have changed their direction,
have leaned into it.
And then they say,
"Now help us."
Some of them,
and it's not just
our companies, of course, say
"Can you help us?
What should we do?
How can we do?
When do we do it?"
OK, we're gonna of course
gonna help,
but the difference
in that conversation is huge.
And so we're seeing a lot of difference
both in the CEOs and how they react
to this crisis.
Incredible. Incredible.
Okay I'm gonna be a little bit selfish now
and I'm gonna ask for some personal advice
because it's pretty rare that
I have the opportunity to chat
for 20 minutes
with somebody like you.
So, I'm starting my journey
like a lot of my friends,
both in 8200 and at Stanford.
We're starting our journeys.
We're trying to become experts
in these different fields,
whether they're in cybersecurity
or AI or diplomacy or whatever.
And now we're gonna go out
to the real world
and we're gonna have to figure out ways
to make a true impact.
And my life goal,
as I'm starting to narrow it down,
is to really move the needle.
To create stuff that has
a positive social impact.
Connect the Jewish world
and Israelis properly.
I know that's something that you're
also very passionate about.
And, you know,
over your years of experiences
and seeing thousands upon thousands
of companies successes and failures.
What are some pro tips that
I can take with me more personally
so that I can keep on this
grit and resilience?
Well, the first thing I would do is
I'd join J-Angels
because the very mission
of what they're doing is in line
with what you're saying.
So, that'd be number one.
Number two, this is tangential to what
you ask, but it'll come back.
And it's something that if I ever stop
doing Zoom calls and e-mails,
I'm going to do.
And I'm gonna write a book on mentorship.
To me, there is nothing more
important than mentorship.
You know it says in
[Hebrew]
Get yourself a rabbi.
It doesn't mean a rabbi.
It really means get yourself a mentor
and not one, but three if you can.
And from the walks of life
that you think
you want to participate in.
Now you can't just put up
a dollar bill and get a mentor.
It doesn't work that way, as you know.
And read my book in 10 years
now and you'll get the hints.
But it's a very very important component
of what I would suggest
to any person starting
because you have a lot to learn.
You know a lot,
but you have a lot to learn.
So, I'd say that's number one.
And number two, define your goals.
Not I'm gonna go into cyber,
I'm gonna go into AI.
That's good.
But I would call define your goals.
I'm going into technology,
into deep technology. Okay.
So, now I have a bucket and I know that
I want it to be in Israel and
I want to help humanity.
OK, well maybe it's something
in the digital health space
as an example.
Or there are so many
great companies springing up.
How do you solve the problem
loneliness in the elderly?
Define a problem that is fits
the criteria or your criteria
that fit the problem.
And then who are
the best people in that space?
Who are the best companies?
Who are  the best mentors?
Who are the best venture capitalists?
And I met a guy who was
a very very senior guy.
Chairman and CEO of a huge company.
And the year before,
00:17:13,010 -> 00:17:15,720
public company, top five, three.
And the year before, or 18 months before,
he knew he was retiring.
He spent that time figuring out
what public boards he wanted to go on,
but not which companies. Which sectors.
He figured that out.
And then he said,
"What are the three
best companies in each sector?"
So, he had 15 companies.
And then he went out
to figure out.
And when he left,
he got the boards he wanted.
So, that's a little bit
later in your career.
But be strategic about it
without overthinking it
'cause young people over think.
Be strategic and then go after
and you can do it.
You have LinkedIn, you have J-Angels
You have your 8200.
When I graduated from college,
my dad was a rabbi.
You know how many connections I had?
You're looking at it right here.
I talk to my kids or to you.
You have a hundred connections
that I never could have dreamed of.
How do they fit into your goals?
It's incredible because so many people
around my community,
and I'm having these conversations now
with former soldiers that I've commanded
and with fellow friends at Stanford
who are a little bit younger than me.
And and they're looking
for advice on where to go.
And there's this constant conflict between
you know this company that pays me
maybe a little bit more per month
or the company that I'm truly excited about
that is perhaps going to
even teach me more.
And it almost seems like
there's a growing social pressure
to make the most amount of money
and your internship,
or to be in the fund that has
the biggest name or something.
But I -
... very sad
That makes me very sad
Because, you know they say
a guy in my generation will have 10 jobs.
A guy in your generation,
a guy or gal, will have 10 careers.
Think about that.
So, that's absurd.
I mean, if you're poor
and you need to put food on the table,
it makes a difference.
Obviously, I'm not talking about that.
But if it's 100 grand versus 80
or 70 or 60 and one you're gonna love.
I wouldn't even have that conversation. It's so simple to me
Right. I mean, definitely.
I think that one of the trends
that I've been seeing talking to
really incredible people through this show
is that the really number one common ground
that everybody has is the passion.
And I'm talking to people
who have a spark in their eyes.
I'm seeing the spark in your eye
and the way that you're talking about
the things that you do in life.
And that's the solution for me
to do things that I feel passionate about,
that I have this intrinsic motivation
and making sure, of course,
that there's food on the table.
But at the end
both myself and a lot of my friends
are lucky to have that.
And we have the privilege of
going and exploring the things
that we're truly passionate about.
Isaac, I wanna thank you
so much for the time.
I have one last question
that I have to ask you.
Three words that you would use
to describe yourself
or that your wife would use
to describe you.
No, the ones that my wife
would not work.
I don't do enough work around the house.
Let's not use that.
I would say I'm a connector.
I love the people
part of anything that I do.
Goal oriented is not fair,
but I'm very focused.
I get a ... in my head
and I wanna go find a winery
and make that a kosher run.
I'm gonna do that.
And I'll tell you,
not the most important thing,
but don't forget about it.
And that's have some fun.
You talk about people in your generation
who maybe take a better job.
I find people who just take themselves
too seriously sometimes.
It's important.
Get a cigar, box of cigars,
get some whiskey, get some wine,
get some friends and enjoy yourself
while you're at the game
'cause you know you're only here once.
I love it.
I think you're your LinkedIn picture
with the cigar is one of my favorite pictures
I've ever seen of anybody.
So it's wonderful.
I'm gonna take that advice to heart.
Isaac, thank you so much
for the inspiration, for the time.
And I look forward to seeing you
in one of the Shabbats.
Sooner than you think.
Wonderful.
Take care.
... great interview.
Thank you.
Bye bye.